President Trump is predicting that the
Islamic state will soon have lost all
the territory that it once controlled in
Iraq and Syria now remember that in late
2014 Isis held major cities throughout
Iraq and Syria US officials say the
group has lost more than 99 percent of
that territory and controls just now two
square miles Charlie d'Agata went close
to that last piece of Isis controlled
land and saw the combat firsthand good
morning well it looks like the
territorial defeat of Isis is now down
to a matter of days is the us-led
coalition and allies on the ground close
in on that last sliver of territory
still under Isis control but in such a
concentrated area the fighting that's
left to be done is in extremely close
quarters an airstrike slammed into an
Isis target much closer than anyone
expected followed immediately by this
whirring noise no one feared to be the
sound of an incoming Isis mortar that
flew right over our heads sending
everyone scrambling gunwale beyond the
wall something just flew over there
soldiers shouted for us to break cover
and run to a safer place reaching the
last strip of isis-held territory meant
to sprint through the desert to avoid
Isis ambushes to an abandoned home now a
Forward Operating Base offering a
glimpse of life in a so-called Caliphate
facing an inevitable end men on
motorcycles women in black burkas now
surrounded on all sides just seconds ago
we heard a jet roaring overhead followed
by two airstrikes in that direction just
showing you that this fight is not over
yet
but it will be soon which many here fear
will speed up the departure of 2000 US
troops who fought beside soldiers like
Syrian democratic forces commander Adnan
offering are you worried about what
might happen after American forces leave
a kid a kid yes there is a worry he told
us we fought together it wasn't a wise
decision it's a decision to leave
halfway through by halfway through the
commander City means what happens
derisive that last bit of territory he
said the terror group has already
established an underground network of
terror cells and hardened fighters who
are ready to regroup and strike back
Vienna
Charlie thank you they're already
reports that Isis is growing in parts of
Africa as well so it should be noted
we've lost a lot number of lives in this
a moment is there a US military has been
doing a fabulous job as well as 30 other
countries and their contributions